Herkese selamlar Ben Mert Gedik 19
yaşındayım Balıkesir Bandırma doğumluyum
çok soruluyor Evet 2003'lüyüm birçoğunuz
gibi akran sayılırız Aslında
benim hikayem aslında tam olarak 8 9
sınıflarda başladı Akademik olarak
başarılı bir insanım orada kimseye
hakkımı yedirmem bizim zamanımızda bir
TEOG sınavı vardı Ve ben o sınavda 240
soruda 3 yanlış yaparak şehrimizin fen
lisesine dereceyle girdim O fen
lisesinden Tabii sonuncu olarak çıktım o
çok ayrı bir konu ama aslında orada
başladı dediğim gibi fen lisesine
geçtiğimde etrafımda o test çözen fizik
sorusu çözen yani kafayı kırmış
üniversite hayalleri için yanıp tutturan
insanlardan biri olmadığımı çok iyi fark
ettim aslında Yani kesinlikle benim
istediğim şey o değildi Ben daha farklı
bir hayat istiyordum gerçekten
hayallerimin peşinden koşabileceğim
kendimi gerçekleştirebileceğim yani o
yolun üniversiteden ya da bir
mühendislik doktorluktan geçmediğini
fark etmiştim
bir yandan da Ben saatlerce bilgisayar
başında vakit geçiren oyun oynayan bir
gençtim o dönem ilk olarak bu fikirlerin
sonucu olarak Birçok yerde anlatmadığım
bir şey aslında bu oyunlarda insanlara
seviye atlatarak para kazanmaya başladım
Bununla ilgili bir web site ve Instagram
sayfası kurdum bunu birçok yakınım bile
bilmez hatta oyun oynayan arkadaşlar
ama ilk serüven böyle başladı
diyebilirim sonrasında bu iş zaten Kısa
vadeli birkaç milyara kazanabileceğiniz
bir işte sonrasında dediğim gibi bu oyun
platformları içerisinde bir gün bir
arkadaşım geldi dedi ki ben dün akşam
searchen diye bir iş yaptım 100 dolar
para kazandım dedi 100 dolar bir gecede
mükemmel para benim çocukken o yani
Liseye giderken harçlığım 10 lira 15
lira mükemmel bir paradan bahsediyordum
sonrasında ben bu işi araştırmaya
başladım nedir ne değildir vesaire diye
ücretsiz eğitimler çıktı karşıma YouTube
videoları birçok yabancı Türkçe
makaleler bloklar hepsini okuduk ve
sonrasında Aslında işin temeli şu;
işletmeleri Google'da sıralama
yükselterek işte onlardan belli bir
hizmetçi ücreti alıyorsunuz Ama bu iş
başlı başına bir uzmanlık işi böyle 3-5
video ile yapılabilecek bir iş değil
kesin kesinlikle ilk harekete geçiş
noktalarından biriydi sonrasında bu
ücretsiz eğitimlerden ve bu search'ten
sonra Amazon dropshipping diye bir iş
çıktı karşıma hayatında işte diyebilirim
stoksuz Ticaret Dünya kıtalar arası
Ticaret yap işte stok tutmadan Ticaret
Oturduğun yerden falan filan ya Neymiş
bu diye bir girdik o günden beri bugüne
zaten amazon'un içindeyiz diyebilirim
o gün kumbaramda böyle iki bayramda
biriktirdiğim paraları patlatıp gidip
bir eğitim almıştım 50 dolara bu işi
öğrenmek için gerçekten çaba sarf
ediyordum olmadı Daha sonrasında başka
bir böyle bu işte sana öğreteceğim diye
gelen bir kişi işte daha farklı ücretler
talep etti Ben bunları karşılamak için
bir kısım annemden borç almak zorunda
kaldım vesaire sonrasında Biz bir Amazon
hesabı açtık bu danışmanlık aldım
dediğim firmayla birlikte bu Amazon
hesabında ürünler yükledik bahsettiğim
dropshipping modeliyle satışa başladık
ben 3 gün sonra bir tane sipariş aldım
Okuldayım öğlen çıktım Telefonu elime
aldım Hiç alışık olmadığım bir bildirim
yazıyor ya bu ne amazon'dan satış gelmiş
nasıl 120 lira kar etmişim 120 lira
devasa bir Para dediğin gibi 10 lira
harçlık alıyorum ya 12 günlük paramı tek
siparişle çıkarmış hemen anneyi arıyorum
abiyi arıyorum böyle böyle şu kadar para
kazandık bu kadar yaptık o günkü
yürüyüşümü bile farklı zaten benim akşam
okuldan çıkarken bir tane daha sipariş
Abi ben zengin oldum ben başardım bu işi
oldu bu sefer başardık
gecesi oldu her şey güzel mükemmel bir
gün geçiriyorum dediğim gibi sokaktaki
yürüyüşüme kadar değişmiş her şey
akşamına amazon'dan binmeyi hesabınız
askıya alındı işte belli politika
ihlalleri sebebiyle vesaire asıl hikaye
orada başladı O gece Çünkü bana bir mail
geldi ve diyor ki paranı işte sana
vermeyeceğiz nasıl vermeyeceksin O Benim
Son param zar zor çekmişim o
siparişlerini zorla demişim zaten derken
siri'den orada başladı Ben bu e-ticaz
sektörüne giriş yaptım cepteki para
kalmadı bu sefer farklı bir birkaç
kişiyle ortaklık yoluna gittim zamanımı
satmaya başladım onların e-ticaret
sitelerini yönetmeye başladım belli bir
ücret karşılığında Hatta o aşamada ilk
bir işbirliği yaptığın kişi tarafından
dolandırıldım diyebilirim Sözde bir
sitenin ortağıydım tüm yönetim işlerini
ben yapıyordum ve elde edilen karı belli
bir payda bölüşecektik ben o karı falan
asla alamadım sonrasında zaten
WhatsApp'tan engelledi gitti ortadan
kayboldu
bir süre sonra ben amazon'dan o parayı
almayı başarabildim para geldiği gibi
dedim ki Tamam yine bir şeyler
denemeliyim Çünkü artık yine param var
Bu arada para da 100 küsur dolar yani bu
kadar düşük bütçelerden bahsediyorum bu
sefer biz yine bir Amazon denedik artık
daha tecrübeliyim vesaire diye bir daha
bir Amazon'da aynı işi yapayım dedim
Daha iyi gitti Dubai tarafında Birleşik
Arap emirliği tarafında daha güzel
satışlar yaptık Daha da tecrübeliydim
zaten Fakat o işte yine 2019'dan Aralık
ayında battı yine hesabın kapandı 3-5
kuruş para kazandık onun ortada kaldık
dedim ki Tamam bu yapılacak bir iş değil
bunu sil kafandan Mert artık Bir buçuk
yıl olmuş bir yol kat edemedim
sonrasında tam o dönemlerde Ben bir Shop
Fire diye bir web site duydum işte
amazon'dan bağımsız kendi web sitenin
kurduğum kurallarını tamamen senin
koyduğun öyle Amazon politikalarının
falan olmadığı birinin sana da oradan
müdahale edemediği bir sistem orada
satış yapmaya başladık ürünler yükledik
işte Reklam yapıyoruz o yapıyoruz bu
yapıyoruz ama buradaki harbi başlık ayrı
bir uzmanlık alanı Zaten ben Facebook
reklamını nereden bileyim Google
reklamını nereden bileyim ne bileyim
ürün bulmayı nereden bileyim mağaza
yapmak Bunların hepsi ayrı bir şey Tabi
bunu da denedik son elde kalan paralarla
Bu işe girdik o dönemde bu yaptığım
platformun Amerika tarafından ödeme
alabilmemiz için bir hizmet almamız
gerekiyordu çünkü Türkiye'de doğrudan
ödeme alamıyorsunuz yurtdışına kredi
kartıyla 100 dolara ben bu hizmeti aldım
bir kişiden O arkadaş da sağ olsun beni
dolandırdı O da gerçekten kumbaramda
kalan son paralardan biriydi ben o 16 ya
da 17 yaşındayım Reşit bile değilim
babamın üzerinden tüketici hakem
heyetine verdim Bu arkadaşı geçen yılda
davayı kazanmışız Hatta onunla ilgili
kararnameye geldi 100 dolar 635 liraymış
o zaman ama o gün gerçekten kumbaramdaki
son parayı vermiştim ona Çünkü işin
başka bir çözümü yoktu o hizmeti
alamazsak bu işi yapamıyorduk çok
faydasını da sağ olsun O arkadaş kapattı
sonrasında tam bu dönemde pandemi
patladı daha Türkiye'ye gelmedi şubatın
10'undan falan bahsediyorum Türkiye'ye
Mart'ın önünde geldi Singapur tarafı
Asya tarafında çok yaygın ya dedim ki
burada nasıl bir fırsat çıkabilir abi
bir baktık Amazon'da maskeler onlar deli
gibi satıyor hemen nasıl tedarik
edebiliriz en yakın ülke Çin zaten
dünyanın Lojistik üretim her şeyin üstü
oradan tedarikçiler buldum dedim hemen
konuştum şöyle şöyle maskeyi alacağız
vesaire daha dediğim gibi Türkiye'de yok
bile ben pandeminin ne olduğunu
bilemiyorum onu kimse olayın
ciddiyetinin farkında değil
allık tedarikçiden bazı sözler bazı
Kargo anlaşmaları vesaire Amazon
Singapur tarafına ben bunları satışını
yapmaya başladım deli gibi sipariş
geliyor her sabah 40-50 sipariş
uyanıyorum hepsini 8-10 tane
maske maskeler de aşırı pahalı benim
alışım 5 dolar lojistiğim 12 dolar
satışım 30 dolar Ya böyle bir ortada
maske piyasası var ve ben orada satış
yapıyorum sonrasında bu dünya genelinde
artık çok çok daha hızlı yayılmaya
başladığında Bu bir serüven bir buçuk ay
sürdü bir buçuk ayın sonunda bizim
tedarikçi kargoları çıkaramamaya malları
tedarik edememeye başladı O aşamada
1000go biz bir daha baktık zaten Çünkü
maske Çok acil bir ihtiyaç Biz insanlara
5-7 gün dolaştırmayı taharet ederken
15-20 günde ulaştıramaz olduk bu
insanlar karşılıksız olarak Tüm parasını
bizden geri aldı amazon'un hepsine
paralarını verdi komisyonlarını bile
verdi zararla çıktık üstüne hesabınızda
askıya aldı içeride bir 40 bin lira para
vardı o da kaldı yine Lanet olsun dedik
onu orada bıraktık Birkaç ay sonra çok
şükür ki onu oradan kurtarmaya başardın
Sonra dedim ki evet tamam bu
dropshipping defteri kapandı stoksuz
taşı satış diye bir mesele yok bu yolda
devam edeceksen seni başka bir yol
bulman lazım ama şu an mesela dönüp o
döneme baktığımda şunu görüyorum ya ya
hacıyatmaz gibiyim yani batıyorsun
batıyorsun çıkıyorsun yine deniyorsun
paralar 100 200 dolar 300 dolar ne varsa
bir şekilde deniyorsun yani sonrasında
bu Singapur döneminde Tabii atladığım
çok önemli bir nokta var Biz aileye
çiftler çiftler kredi kartı çıkarmışız
bu maskeden siparişlerini
karşılayabilmek için Çünkü Cepte para
yok stoksuz Satış yapıyoruz ya
müşteriden para geliyor Amazon'da
bekliyor Biz o arada kredi kartından
çekiyoruz malı alıyoruz abim annem babam
hepsinde kredi kartları dibine kadar
doldu işin sonunda amazon'dan para
gelmeyince İki seçenek kaldı bana ya
bizim eve haciz gelecekti kredi kartları
borcu ödenmeyecekti ya da annemin
altınlarını almak zorundaydım daha başka
bir yol yok çünkü sağ olsun annem de o
dönemde bana yardımcı oldu bu sorumda
bir şekilde atlattık ondan 3 ay sonra
Temmuz ayında ben bu içeride kalan
parayı aldım Anneme borcu ödedikten
sonra yine ele Düşüp bir sermaye kaldı
dedim ki bu sefer yapacaksa toplu
tarafına artık gerçek bir iş olarak yap
deyip başladık bir şey Amazon hesabı
kalmadı elinde ama bütün hesaplar askıya
alındı ama o zaman sen benim
platformunda satış yapamazsın diye beni
her yerden atmış düşündüm ne yapabilirim
diye Facebook grupları var O zamanlar
Facebook grub
sonrasında Tabii bu taraftaki işleri
büyüttük daha da farklı noktalara gitti
bu bir Amerika'da şirket kurma mevzu
gerekti bizim için Çünkü o taraftaki
toptancılarla da anlaşmak istiyorduk
cepte yine olan sermayeler çok düşük
olduğu için o zaman 13.000 liraya
kuracaktım 1800 dolar 13.000 lirayı ben
gittim annemin üzerinden kredi çektim
Çünkü ya onun adı Para versek zaten elde
bir şey kalmayacak Ondan sonra Amerika
tarafında da bir Ticaret yapmaya
başladık zaten Türkiye'de şirketlerimizi
kurmuştuk her şeyi legal bir şekilde
yapıyorduk derken işler kendi kendine
iyileşmeye başladı Bir süre sonra bizim
bir sermaye problemimiz de olur Çünkü
işleri çok güzel büyüttük çok fazla ürün
buluyoruz potansiyeliniz çok yüksek
Tabii arkada artık bir ekip oluştu fakat
bunları karşılayabilecek bir sermaye yok
yani 17-18 yaşında bir çocuksanız ne
kadar paranız olabilir yaptığınız iş
zaten boyunuzdan büyük sonrasında Biz
yurt dışında Amazon satırına yatırım
yapan birçok firma var Bunları
araştırmaya başladık Aslında ilk yola
kredilerle çıktık yani bankalardan kredi
alsak nasıl olur falan diye Tabii Bütün
bankaların kapısından döndük Yani kim
verecek 17 yaşındaki çocuğa Kredi ya da
babası annesi Üzerine de benim annem
memur babam işçi yani çok bir kredi
değil de olabilecek bir durum yok ortada
Amerika'dan bir firma bulduk Bu firma
Amazon satıcılarına yatırım yapıyor elde
edilen kardan pay alarak çalışıyor
birçok firma vardı bu firmayı seçtik o
firmadan yatırım aldık Biz 53 bin dolar
o dönem Ondan sonra onu kullandık etteki
işlerimizi büyüttük vesa ederken Mayıs
ayında geçtiğimiz ya dedik ki insanların
da böyle çok büyük bir problemi var biz
bu firmayı niye Türkiye'ye getirmiyoruz
yani Türkiye'ye gelse bu firma burada
birçok Amazon satıcısı var 10 binlerce
satıcı var Özellikle bu ekonomik krizin
tırmanması ile birlikte satıcı sayısı
git gide artıyor Çünkü insanlar bir
şekilde Oturduğum yerden nasıl para
kazanabilirim ve daha çok odaklanıyor
bu firmaya bir mail attık toplantılar
yaptık dedik ki Türkiye'de böyle böyle
bir pazar var burada çok büyük bir iş
çıkar Sonra firmanın Türkiye Partner
oldu Biz bir şekilde anlaştık bir buçuk
iki ay süren bir süreç oldu Türkiye
partileri oldu bu firmanın firmanın adı
da ekrum yaptı bu firmayı Türkiye'ye
Getirdik Bir yılı geçti bir yıldır
birlikte çalışıyoruz onlarla bu
taraftaki Amazon satıcılarını onların
yatırım almaları için yardımcı oluyoruz
diyebilirim Aslında olay bir yerden
sonra tamamen şuna döndü Her gördüğüm
problemi çözmeye döndü Çünkü bir dönem
benim çok büyük bir vergi şirket
muhasebe fatura kesme bunları nasıl
yapacağız gibi problem vardı çünkü biz
çok karışık bir ticaret yapıyoruz
aslında kıtalar arası bir ticaret Ben
Türkiye'de yaşıyorum şirketin Türkiye'de
mala Amerika'da para Avrupa'da müşteri
Kanada'da Ben bunu gidip bir mali
müşaviri açıklayamam yani
açıklayamıyordum da zaten mali
Müşavirleri Amazon belgelerine
götürdüğümde bunları Türkçe getir bana
diyordu yok zaten haber gelmedi Türkçesi
yok Olsa götürürüm
Bu benim için çok büyük bir problemdi
fakat biz bu Amazon içinde yaptığımız
çoğu şeyi yazılımlarla yapıyoruz dedim
ki biz bunun bunları da niye yazılımla
yapamıyoruz ya Niye ben faturamı
otomatik olarak yazılım kesmiyor vergimi
başka şekilde ödeyemiyorum beyannameler
otomatik olarak verilmiyor Sonuçta
ortada her şey Amazon üzerinden dönüyor
ve oradan bilgiler gelse faturalar
kesilse Bunlar mali müşavirine
gönderirse çok iyi olur diye Aslında
bireysel olarak ortaya çıkan bir proje
oldu sonrasında Biz bunu tabii çok çok
daha geliştirdik işte adında sedirin oy
söyledik çok kısa bir süre sonra 15-20
gün gibi bir süreçte zaten web sitesini
açacağız Bu benim yaklaşık 15-1,5 yıllık
çalıştığım bir proje e-ticaret
satıcıları hatta çok genelleyebilirim
dijital de satış yapan ya da bunu
youtuberlara da katabilirsiniz freelance
çalışanları da katabilirsiniz herkesin
vergi vermeye şirket kurma mali müşavir
fatura kesme KDV beyanı vesaire
aklınızda muhasebesi olarak gelecek her
detayları çözen bir proje ortaya koyduk
Aslında ve dediğim gibi onda çok kısa
sürede çıkaracağız bundan öncekiler hep
bir ticarete bir faaliyete yönelikti ama
bu gerçekten artık bir startup olan
benim de gerçekten Yakında bütün o adamı
vereceğim çok büyük bir iş olacak bugün
bugüne kadarki işlerin beni gerçekten
bir seviyeye getirdi ama sevdiğim hoşsun
beni çok ayrı bir seviyeye götüreceğini
Yani global'e gerçekten açılmamdaki en
büyük etken olacağını ve gerçekten çok
ciddi bir start-up doğacağını çok iyi
eminim
şu an size Mesela bu konuşmanda yaklaşık
7-8 farklı küçük minik girişimden
bahsettim ama bunları yapan insan da
minikti zaten 14-15-16 yaşlarındaydı o
dönemlerde kendime dönüp baktığımda tek
gördüğüm şey aslında çok ciddi bir
adammıştık kafayı takmışım kırmışım
kafayı ya Yani ne olursa olsun dönüyorum
tekrar yapıyorum dönüyorum tekrar
yapıyorum Ben hep söylerim zaten benim
bin kere Düşme bir problem değil ben
Binbir kere kalkmayı Bilirim Her
seferinde Düşmüşüz bir yerden parasını
bulmuşuz bir yerden borç almışız bir
yolunu bulmuşuz ya bana bu serüvenlerimi
anlattığımda sosyal medyada çok fazla
soru geliyor benim param yok benim şöyle
bir durumum var vesaire Ben genel olarak
bakış açısı olarak fakirliğe de çok bir
inanan bir insan değilim zaten bir insan
fakir olabilir Bir yıl fakir olabilir
iki yıl fakir olabilir ama gerçekten
ciddi bir planla bir projeyle ben bir
insana 5 yıl fakir kalabileceğine
İnanmıyorum Bu gerçekten insanın
kendisine yaptığı bir hatadır bana göre
o yüzden sermaye de yaratılır fikir de
bulunur ama burada çok fazla Detay var
Ben olayı 3 maddeyle Öz Aslında
birincisi Hepimiz bir şeylerimizden
feragat etmek zorundayız Kimimiz
zamanımızdan Kimimiz paramızdan Kimimiz
kariyerimizden Ben okulu mu yaktım ben
fen lisesine 10 olarak girdim sonuncu
olarak çıktım üniversite bir şekilde bir
yere girdik ona da hiç gitmedim zaten
lise mezunu olarak kaldık ben okulumu
yaktım zamanımı yaktım 9 oyununuzu
sınıfta evden çıkmaya asosyalin tekiydim
bilgisayar başındaydım Sadece bütün
sosyal hayatımı bitirmiştim bu aslında
bir yandan bilinçli olan bir şey değildi
Gerçekten bunu istiyordum Onu başarana
kadar oradan kalkmak istemiyordum bir
arkadaşınla görüşmek istemiyordum çünkü
kafamda sadece iş var
ikinci kısım bana göre herkes boyuna
göre bir şekilde risk alabilmeli yani
risk almadığı sürece harekete geçmez bir
şey yapmaz mümkün değil Sizin risk
baremeniz 50 dolardır benimki 1000
dolardır fark etmez
amanki Mert 14-15 yaşındaki Mert Kumbar
asındaki sıkıldı Siz de benzer şeyler
yapabilirsiniz Yani imkansızlıkları bir
an yani bahane olarak kafaya takmanın
çok bir anlamı yok ülkenin durumu şöyle
kötü dolar bu kadar arttı Tamam Bunlar
dış etken bunları değiştiremezse seni
doları düşürme gibi bir yetkin ya da bir
bilgin yok buna müdahale edemiyorsan sen
bunu niye kafaya takıyorsun ki hayatını
değiştirmeye odaklan Yani bu taraf bana
çok mantıksız gelen kısımlar açıkçası
bir anlamda en önemli madde bana göre
Harekete Geçmek herkesin kafasına bir
fikir var herkesin Kafasında bir fikir
var Ama Batar mıyız ama çıkar mıyız işte
para kaybeder miyiz yok başarılı olur mu
Şu olur mu bu olur mu ya Bir şeyler
yapmak zorunda lazım harekete geçmen
lazım adım attıktan sonra karşısına
çıkacak zaten her şey ama herkesin
Kafasında bir plan kimsede harekete
geçecek kimisine güç yok kimisine irade
yok kimisinde inanç yok bunun en büyük
temellerinden biri de Özgüven olabilir
Bana göre
bu üç madde olduğu sürece başarı
kaçınılmaz gibi geliyor bana ben 5
yıldır bu işi yapıyorum tam 5 yıl olacak
2018'in temmuzunda başlamışım o günden
Facebook'a yazdığım yazılar var elimde
şunu nasıl yapıyoruz bunu nasıl
yapıyoruz diye çok basit sorular
hiçbirinin cevabı Google'da YouTube'da
yoktu o zaman Çünkü bu sektör bu kadar
gelişmiş değildi şimdi bir çoğunuz çok
daha şanslısınız hepsinin onlarca
videosu var en azından benim kanalımda
bile var o yüzden artık çok daha rahat
bir şeyler fakat artık bahane üretmek
için de çok sebebimiz var benim param
yok benim zamanım yok vesaire Peki o
zaman bulunduğun durumun değiştirmeni de
çok bir seçeneği yok gibi gözüküyor
umarım Siz bu söylediğim 3 maddeyi
uygulayabilenlerden olursunuz harekete
geçenlerden olursunuz diyorum Hepinize
teşekkürler
[Alkış]